today we'll be talking about the meta
learning problem and black box meta
learning uh
I'm pretty I don't know this is like the
first time we'll actually see some of
the kind of core metal learning topics
which I think is pretty exciting uh
they're actually pretty cool when you
look into how they work
um for some less interesting Logistics
so the optional homework zero is due
tonight at midnight
we're also going to be posting homework
one today and it will be due on
Wednesday next week we're also going to
post the Azure guide today as well
um basically homework one will be using
gpus and you'll be able to uh
you'll be able to use Azure if you don't
have access to a GPU and we have a guide
for getting that all set up and stuff
and so forth we'd encourage you to kind
of try to start getting set up on azure
earlier rather than later in case you
run into any any catches or anything
like that
great So the plan for today first we're
going to be talking about transfer
learning which we didn't get to last
time we'll talk about the problem
formulation and fine-tuning which is the
kind of predominant approach for
transfer learning and then we'll talk
about meta learning including the
problem formulation a fairly General
recipe of meta learning algorithms as
well as a certain class of metal
learning approaches called Black Box
approaches
I mean if you have some time we'll also
go through gpt3 although I suspect we
probably won't have time for that and
we'll probably go over it in a future
lecture
and also these kind of first three
bullet points are the topic of homework
one you'll be implementing Black Box
metal learning algorithms
um yeah so uh
this lecture will be helpful for that
cool um so the goals by the end of the
lecture are to understand the
differences between multitask learning
transfer learning and meta learning
problems
um understand some of the basics of
transfer learning and then also get into
the details of metal learning including
the overall training setup and how to
implement techniques like black box meta
learning techniques
okay so let's get started with transfer
learning so uh
last week we talked about multitask
learning where our goal was to solve
multiple tasks all at the same time and
we looked at the subjective function
where we had a loss function for each
task with a corresponding data set for
each task and we were trying to optimize
a network that can solve all of the
tasks simultaneously and leverage the
data from different tasks in order to
try to improve performance compared to
training a task independently
now in transfer learning uh the goal is
a little bit different uh the overall
goal you can think of
it as trying to solve a particular
Target task after having solved some
Source task
and the way that you try to do this is
essentially trying to transfer knowledge
or information from the source task to
the Target task
um and usually in this sort of setup you
assume that the source task has is is
fairly Rich for example trading on
imagenet is a very common source task
whereas the target task might be
something that is more narrow or more
specialized and you want to be able to
kind of Leverage the rich and diverse
information from the source task when
trying to solve the target task
now one key assumption in transfer
learning approaches is that you
typically can't directly access the
source data during the transfer process
itself
and this is unlike the multitask
learning setup whereas in multitask
learning you typically have all the
tasks at once whereas in transfer
learning you previously learned task a
you have some maybe some some
pre-trained weights or something like
that about what you learned about Tasca
but you can't directly access the
original data set for example if you're
trying to transfer from imagenet to like
a medical imaging problem for example
storing all of image data and using that
might be quite expensive when you're
trying to solve the target task
um it's worth mentioning that transfer
learning is a valid solution to
multitask learning uh you can if you
want to if you care about one of your
tasks in particular you can try to solve
a previous task and then transfer to
that Target task
um but not vice versa so uh in transfer
learning you really care about the
target task whereas a multitask learning
ultimately you are trying to optimize
the loss for multiple tasks
okay
um so a question for you what are some
problems or applications where you think
that transfer learning might make a lot
of sense relative to multitask learning
any thoughts yeah
so the example was image classification
where maybe you have some existing model
for image classification and then you
want to transfer that to a different
image classification problem yeah
yeah so if you have limited data in task
B you want to leverage kind of the
information from task a and that's a
scenario where probably translating
would make a lot of sense multitask
learning may also make a lot of sense if
you have the information in task a
available
foreign
data and that's your your Source task
and you want to leverage the information
from that unlabeled data when solving a
Target test
any other thoughts
yeah
like Source space
yeah so if the source data set is really
large and you don't want to have to
actually train on this really huge data
set when solving your target task it
might be a lot cheaper computationally
and more practical computationally to
um to Instead try to transfer uh kind of
a more compact representation of the
knowledge in task a
okay
um so this is actually one of the the
examples um that I put up on the slides
is if your Source data set is very large
you don't want to have to retain and
retrain on the source data set every
single time you want to solve a
downstream Target task
um
and then another scenario where it might
make sense is maybe you don't actually
care about solving both A and B for
example maybe a is self-supervised or
maybe it's some some previous image
classification tasks that you no longer
care about and you really want to focus
on this target task B then this sort of
transfer learning scenario can make
sense because it allows you to kind of
try to leverage the knowledge from task
a without necessarily having to solve
task a
yeah
yeah
[Music]
so the point is that um the point that
was brought up is that uh you may also
have a fairly large data set for task B
and maybe it takes a lot of time to
learn that and you want to jump start
that optimization process by leveraging
a model that you already trained on a
previous task
okay
um and so I'll cover one approach for
transfer learning which is referred to
as fine-tuning many of you have I would
guess have encountered fine-tuning and
other courses or other experiences and
the way that fine-tuning works is you
have some pre-trained parameters that
were trained just on your Source task
and then you run gradient descent on the
training data for the new task so you
initialize the weights with
um with something that was traded on
task a and then you run gradient descent
this is just showing one step of
gradient descent in reality you would
run probably many steps of gradient
descent on the data for your Target task
okay
um and so as you actually look at
transfer learning compared to training
from scratch you can see pretty large
performance gains in a number of
scenarios so for example if you
pre-train on imagenet versus if you
start from scratch with a random
initialization you can see an
improvement from 41 to 58 on the Pascal
data set and 35 to 52 on the Sun data
set
um and so in this case the pre-trained
parameters came from imagenet but uh in
general the pre-trained parameters may
come from a variety of sources they can
come from images that they could come
from Models trained on a large language
corpora
um using some sort of unsupervised or
self-supervised technique
uh really whatever large and diverse
data set you might have access to or
whatever large pre-trained models you
might have access to that you think
might be related and useful for the
Target tasks you're trying to solve
um another thing that's really nice
about this sort of technique is you
don't even have to actually store The
Source data set anywhere in many cases
you can actually just go and download a
pre-trained model from the internet and
run fine tuning from there
so these kinds of preteen models
um are often available online and
they're reusable for many different
Target tasks
okay now
all of a sudden fine tuning is like a
really great technique but there are
some sort of different practices to try
to get fine-tuning to work better and
there isn't this is really more of an
art than a science so people have
considered a number of different
practices like trying to fine tune with
a smaller learning rate than your
original learning rate and the goal of
this is to try not to erase the
knowledge in the pre-trained model
um sometimes it makes sense to use a
smaller learning rate for earlier layers
because often the earlier layers of the
network have information that is more
General about the inputs
also some models that actually just
completely freeze the earlier layers and
only fine-tune the um the later laters
or gradually unfreeze them as it has
learned the higher level representations
another approach is to Simply
re-initialize the last layer or put a
head on top of the network that you're
going to train but keep everything else
fixed
um and then in general there's all these
kind of hyper parameters or things that
you can try with fine-tuning and
oftentimes what you can do is you can
just hold out a subset of your target
task and use cross validation to figure
out which um which kind of technique
works best for the fine-tuning process
okay um it's also worth mentioning that
architecture choices here also matter a
lot so for example residual networks
have been found to be core quite well
for fine-tuning because they lead to
gradients that are better behaved
okay any questions on fine-tuning
okay
um and so uh here's an example of fine
tuning on a text classification problem
where it was pre-training using a a
language model and fine-tuning using uh
three different text classification
problems uh from IMDb Trek 6 and AG
and what you see here is each of these
plots is showing the the x-axis is
showing the number of training examples
in the Target task and the y-axis is
showing the validation error rate on
that Target task and so what we see is
overall of course as you have more
examples you do better on the target
task but we also see a big Improvement
between learning from scratch I'm sorry
the big improvement from using the
pre-trained model compared to learning
from scratch
um the only thing that you might notice
here is that uh as you move towards
fewer and fewer training examples
fine tuning still helps a lot over
learning from scratch but it doesn't
work as well as when you have a lot of
examples and so for example when you
have only 100 training examples or even
fewer than 100 training examples you
might not expect fine tuning to work
very well
um yeah
yeah so in this case um what the
supervised versus semi-supervised means
is that the supervised example is using
labeled data from the target task and
the semi-supervised example is using
that label data as well as unlabeled
data that's also available and so it's
using additional data in this case and
it's running supervised learning on on
the target objective the classification
objective and it's using the unlabeled
data with a language modeling objective
and so that's what it's referred to as
semi-supervised
yeah absolutely so when the data set is
small essentially what happens is that
it either
um it either still overfits to that
because
um because you are still trading on a
relatively small data set or maybe you
tune the hyper parameter so that it
doesn't overfit but it doesn't change
the source model enough to actually
sufficiently solve the task
okay
um yeah
exactly so that's why this access starts
at 100 if you move even further to the
left it gets even worse yeah
so transferring the weights is certainly
the most popular approach there are
other approaches in um in the domain
adaptation literature you can also use
things like multitask learning most of
the other approaches for transferring
information
either just transfer the weights
typically or they assume that you have
access to the data all the data from The
Source task and try to use that data
instead of using the weights or or in
addition to using the weights
um and then of course another approach
that we'll talk about right after this
is how metal learning can actually be
useful for leveraging
um for leveraging the source data in a
way that can actually work well with
very small amounts of data and of the
target task
right so the question is can you
transfer learn across different network
architectures
um in general
with fine-tuning you do assume that the
architecture for the source task and the
target task is the same you might add a
couple layers on top or you might chop
some layers off of the source
architecture but in general it's going
to be a fairly similar architecture at
least the first few layers of the
networks have to be the same
okay
um so now let's talk a bit about meta
learning and how we can actually
learn Target tasks with very small
amounts of data by essentially learning
how to learn different Source tasks
um and so to start let's actually just
cover the problem statement of meta
learning um and this is the problem
statement that we'll consider in this
class there are other ways to think
about the meta learning problem
statement as well
um and happy to chat about those
separately
okay um so there's really two ways to
view meta learning algorithms uh and
we'll discuss both of them in the course
one will refer to as more of a
mechanistic view which is thinking about
how to implement algorithms and how they
actually work uh in terms of their
underlying mechanisms and the second
view is more of a probabilistic view
which ties into
nice intuition with regard to
probabilistic graphical models and
thinking about things in terms of priors
and posteriors
and so from the mechanistic standpoint
the way that meta learning algorithms
work is they essentially have a model
that reads in an entire data set and
makes predictions for new data points
and then you train this network itself
with a metadata set or a data set of
data sets
such that it's kind of trained to read
in data sets and make predictions and
generalize from data sets across a set
of data sets
so essentially it's learning how to
learn from a set of data sets and this
is why it's referred to as as metal
learning so it's explicitly optimizing
for the ability to to learn from data
sets
um and the more probabilistic view is
instead of thinking about it in terms of
reading and data sets and making
predictions instead use the meta
learning process as trying to extract
prior knowledge from a set of tasks
and then using that prior knowledge to
quickly solve new tasks
and then from this standpoint you can
essentially view it as learning a task
that uses a prior and a small training
set to infer a posterior over the
parameters for that new task
um so we're going to be talking about
both of these used for now we're going
to focus primarily on The mechanistic
View but when we talk about Bayesian Med
learning we're going to talk about the
probabilistic view and uh the
probabilistic view does uh
does end up being quite nice in terms of
intuition and thinking about
um the problem but I think that the
mechanistic standpoint is a little bit
easier for just understanding how things
work from the beginning
um so we'll have uh Bayes come back
later
so
how does meta learning work
um we're going to run through an example
of kind of the problem set up in the
training setup and then we'll talk about
how algorithms go about solving this
training set
so
as we saw in the first lecture
we are going to look at an example where
we want to be able to perform image
classification
and we're given a really tiny training
data set
this training data set has five examples
one example of five different classes
and we want to be able to use this tiny
draining data set in order to classify
new examples
um so this is essentially our test set
uh and of course like we saw um in the
first lecture humans are are pretty good
at solving problems with very small
amounts of data
um including in scenarios where you
haven't seen these classes before
but if you train from scratch or even if
you fine-tuned on this tiny amount of
data you wouldn't be able to generalize
to new examples very well
so this is what we want to be able to do
essentially at a test time we want the
model to be able to perform this few
shot classification problem
and so the way that meta learning
algorithms work is they try to create a
training setup that prepares the model
to solve these kinds of problems
and uh the way that you can do that in
the standpoint of machine learning is
that this this is what you want to do at
test time that at training time you
should give it examples of solving
problems like this
so what we can do is we can give it kind
of mini train sets and mini test sets
and train the model to solve these kinds
of problems so that it can generalize to
exam test examples from training sets
so that after it's seen kind of all of
these different training tasks it can
eventually solve the problem at the
bottom
so each of these rows will be are just
different classification tasks these are
constructed using a set of training
classes and then so this is kind of the
meta training process
and then at what I'll call Meta test
time we want to be able to learn a new
task
using the tiny training data set and
this is a kind of a held out test task
um and it has a training data set and a
test set and this training set and test
set exactly mimics the kinds of training
sets and test sets we'll see during the
meta training process
yeah exactly so the examples on the top
right in the blue rectangles these are
not actually held out from The Meta
training process
um they are they are being used to test
the model's generalization on that
particular task but these are kind of
the training classes and then these are
the examples that are completely held
out these examples down here and
um these will be kind of uh yeah classes
that are held out from the the training
classes uh used for meta training
yeah so the question is is transfer
learning Superior to metal learning when
there's a domain shift
um and in particular one thing that you
might notice is that we're trying to
prepare we're trying to make it so that
training and test time match
uh so that we're essentially preparing
it for solving this sort of
classification problem and if you do
have a task that is out of distribution
from what you're trading it on then it
may not work well because that's not
what you prepared it for and in those
kinds of scenarios transfer learning can
um
can sometimes perform better than metal
learning kinds of approaches
now each of these rows corresponds to a
different image classification task
but in reality you can really replace
image classification with really any
sort of machine learning task you can
replace it with different regression
problems you can replace it with
different language generation problems
different skill learning problems and so
forth
and you can also potentially combine it
with um with really a variety of machine
learning problems the most important
thing is that the task that you're
seeing here
is within the distribution of tasks that
it's used during meta training
so we're essentially raising machine
learning up to the level of tasks
okay um so you can think of the meta
learning problem as given data from a
number of tasks quickly learn a new test
task
um and one key assumption is that these
meta training and meta test tasks are
sampled IID from the same task
distribution
and so we can think of it as having some
distribution over
over tasks and then sampling them from
that same distribution
um and like before like in multitask
learning and transfer learning you also
want these tasks to share some structure
if they are completely random tasks then
even if they're drawn IID you won't be
able to do better at the test task than
learning from scratch
okay um so what did the tasks actually
correspond to
um I gave an image classification
example on the previous slide it could
also be something like recognizing
handwriting digits from different
languages and this is the example that
we'll see in homework one
it could also correspond to giving
feedback to students on different exams
where different exam problems correspond
to different tasks that you need to be
able to give feedback on
I will see an example of this in in two
lectures I think
um it could also correspond to
classifying species in different regions
of the world where different regions
correspond to different tasks
it could also correspond to a robot
performing different tasks as well where
it wants to learn a new skill or a new
task by leveraging experience solving
previous tasks
now another natural question is how many
tasks do you need
for the this whole meta training process
and in general it's really a case of the
more the better essentially
Mediterranean or meta learning
algorithms treat tasks as data points
and
um analogously in machine learning the
more data you have the better and so I'm
better learning the more tasks you have
the better
what does it means
yeah that's a great question
the so there's different ways that you
can look about look at the
um there's different ways of
representing different kinds of tasks
um
let me think of a good example so
I mean as one simple example um you
could say that uh
say that you want different tasks
correspond to like a robot running at
different velocities
um like one task is to run like as fast
as possible one task is dirt like do a
very slow Trot something like that then
your task distribution would correspond
to those like correspond essentially
just different velocities and you would
assume that you have some distribution
of velocities uh
you have some distribution of velocities
and the training tasks are sampled from
that distribution of velocities and the
test tasks are sampled from that
distribution of velocities
now that's one example they're also
going to be examples where you might not
have this nice parametric way to specify
tasks
and in those cases it gets a little bit
murkier per se
um
you can also think of when we Define
tasks
um
two lectures ago we also we defined it
as kind of a distribution over X and a
distribution over y given X at least for
supervised learning problems and in this
case you can if you can essentially
somehow parametrize these distributions
then you can think of the
um the distribution over tasks as being
a distribution over those parameters
um so if these are parametrized by five
for example then you would assume that
you have some distribution over Phi
um in practice you may not always have
this nice parametric form for your tasks
what's the difference between like these
different tasks and like difficulties
versus just having like one big
assignment
if you're asking what's the difference
between having
um like like breaking it down into
different tasks comparing to have like a
single data set with all the tasks of it
[Music]
yeah so essentially the the important
thing here is we want to be able to
learn a new task we want like maybe the
robot has acquired a bunch of previous
skills and now it wants to like learn
how to ride a bike or like skateboard or
something like that
um
one of the things that's pretty
important in The Meta learning problem
statement and we'll see why this is
later is to actually break down the
previous experience into these different
tasks
um and that allows you to try to extract
the shared structure between those tasks
and ultimately learn a new task
and if you don't have it broken down
into those different tasks then it's
much more difficult to try to quickly
very quickly learn a new task like
skateboarding
is
yeah so I guess I should have also said
you could also have you have a loss
function for each task as well and that
could also be potentially parametrized
or something um the um
and yeah so different tasks can vary in
these different ways they could only
they could choose to only vary in this
way they could choose to only vary in
this way and so forth
um I think that it's probably most
common for different metal learning
tasks to vary
um in the data and not in the loss
function
um but in principle you can
um you can vary any aspect of it or
choose a not vary any aspect of it as
well
this is
yeah so the question is is there a way
to determine ahead of time which
approach to take what did it take a
metal learning approach or a transfer
learning approach
um in general there isn't any formula
that will tell you which approach to use
um
although hopefully over kind of the
course of the kind of next couple weeks
you'll be able to get some intuition
about which approaches might be more
suitable
the question is is there a way to um is
it something that tells us how to order
the tasks in a way that
um will help make it easier to solve the
test task
uh I guess the short answer is that's
that's an open problem I think
um also one interesting problem beyond
that is not even ordering but can we
pick the set of training tasks that will
be most useful for learning the target
task rather than um and then from there
also picking the ordering and so forth
as we'll see later you we do actually
train it on all the tasks at once
essentially rather than training on them
one at a time and there is a little bit
of work on studying curriculum learning
but in general it's an open problem
yeah so the question is what if it's
what if the task is somewhat continuous
like the velocity of a robot
um in that case we will still be
sampling tasks for training um and so
we'll be sampling numbers from a
distribution over velocities
um you can choose to sample every single
iteration of training and so you don't
necessarily need to have a finite number
of tasks if you have infinite that the
more the better and that's great if you
have access to that
so the question is how do you assured
that tasks are drawn IID from the
distribution
um
it really depends on the problem uh you
want to
the most important thing is to try to
have the the test task be drawn from a
similar distribution
um
and not be completely out of
distribution or like significantly
feeling harder or significantly easier
than the tasks that you saw during
training
okay
um one more question
um
online
so yeah so the question is what are some
strategies for overcoming domain shift
we'll talk about this
um next lecture a little bit
okay and then we can answer more
questions a little bit later uh or maybe
some of the slides will answer them
okay so I want to go over some
terminology
so in the example that I showed before
we have these meta training tasks and
meta test tasks
each
data set each training data set for a
task can be referred to as the task
training set and so if a task is indexed
with I then I'll use D train I to refer
to that
and then each task also has a
corresponding test set for that task
sometimes these are also referred to as
the support set and the query set I'll
also be using this terminology it's
helpful to use support set and query set
for these trade-in test sets because it
distinguishes it from training tasks and
test tasks or meditating tasks and meta
testing tasks
um and then in general if we want to
learn with a small number of examples we
refer to that as k-shot learning where
we assume that we have K examples per
class
um or if you're like in a regression
scenario you just have K examples total
so for example in one shot learning
we'll have one example per class
and then
in anyway classification essentially the
model will be choosing between and
different classes
uh so a question for you um what is k n
for this example here
yeah for today's one this one yeah
here's one in this type because we're
doing five-way classification and each
of our support sets has one example for
each of the five classes
okay
um so this is kind of the notation and
terminology that we'll be using
throughout the next several lectures
including in the homework yeah
it's not what God has deserved exactly
causing the multitude
images
yeah so essentially what we're going to
be trying to do is learn from the
training data sets and we want to be
able to learn from the training data
sets in a way that generalizes we don't
just want to be able to like memorize
the training examples and so these these
test sets shown in the red boxes are
essentially going to be testing the
model's ability to generalize
um I'm showing just two examples here uh
for conciseness on the slides and in
reality this could be different sizes it
could be one example per class it could
be larger than that it could be smaller
than that it should be at least one to
measure generalization but it could be
different sizes
entertainment
right so
um and includes essentially the number
of the the
classification problem that each of
these tasks involves
um in reality you may be doing meta
training with many more than five
classes or many more than
um n classes so for example you might
notice here that like we see classes
like bird mushroom singer piano in the
first example and we see classes like
landscape tank Barrel that sort of thing
and so we actually have more than five
classes that are being used in this meta
training process but the classification
problem that's being solved at metatest
time is a five-way classification
yeah so the question is is it easier
harder to learn with more or less
classes if n is larger that's harder
because it has to distinguish more
classes from one another
um although if you so larger N means
it's harder if you have a lot of classes
to choose from in the Mediterranean
process but n is held constant that
generally makes it easier because you
have more data to learn from and more
essentially more tasks
yeah it's a great question so does this
k n need to be the same across all the
tasks um it doesn't it can it can be
different for different tasks um you
want to make sure that you don't have a
harder meta test task than at meditating
and so you shouldn't Set n to be like
larger than any of the trading tasks and
for Simplicity it's all the same here
but it can be different for different
tasks
about existing course because they are
all angles are there in that case that
you would be oh but I can also think not
this one don't analyze these two
separate classes so in that case that
you would be fine so she can be fixed
for me for each house yes okay can be
different for different tasks um you
don't
um yeah so it can be different in this
case the uh it's considering like uh
dogs and lions to be uh different
classes because it's a more fine-grained
classification problem but in general K
can can vary across the tasks
okay
um so to recap the different problems we
talked about multitask learning where we
want to learn a set of tests transfer
learning where we want to transfer from
one task to another task
and in the middle earning problem we
assume that we have a set of previous
tasks we want to quickly learn a new
task
and so this is somewhat similar to
multitask learning in that we have
multiple tasks however unlike multitask
learning we're trying to learn a new
task and we're trying to learn a new
task efficiently
um and it's really the transfer learning
in the sense that we want to learn a new
task except that
we actually assume that we have multiple
previous tasks that we're going to learn
from
um during the training process
yeah
um
yeah exactly so we typically assume that
you don't have access to these training
tasks but like you don't have access to
the test task in the train test at the
same time if you did have access to them
at the same time then you could use
multitask learning and instead we're
going to be in a scenario where we kind
of meditate some sort of Prior from the
tasks and use that to quickly solve a
new task
it's trying to do like an end-way
classification for all of these
set that like beetles right
um
I'll give you two images and five images
that's probably which passes they are
not just like thrown out there it still
happens it doesn't need a shot at all
yes I think the question is like can we
just kind of combine all the classes
together and just use kind of standard
classification
foreign
so if you've never seen like
um these classes before if you've never
seen ice cream and dogs and so forth you
won't necessarily know what the
corresponding class label is for that we
are going to see approaches next week
that look a little bit more like zero
shot learning in some way
um
but in general unless typically for zero
shot learning approaches you need some
description or some metadata or
something to tell you about what the
task is
um otherwise you won't you simply just
won't know
um kind of how like what to output for
lion for example or what to output for
Bull and so forth like what the model
should be outputting what the class
label corresponds to
uh see for each test image
yeah exactly
zero shot learning that will be
um on I think Monday next week and those
will look a lot more like their assault
learning approaches
yeah so the question is are there
examples of
um actually being able to like learn new
tasks quickly using Med learning uh and
I I guess the short answer is yes
um and the I mean we've seen us all try
to cover some different applications of
meta learning in the next few lectures
but one example that we'll see
um
we applied metal learning to education
and we were able to
um essentially give feedback on an
entirely new exam where instructors of
the course essentially gave feedback on
a small number of examples and then the
system was able to give feedback on the
remainder of the students exams
okay
um so
going back to the problem setting
um in transfer learning and metal
learning is generally assumed to be
impractical to access the previous tasks
so maybe we have a lot of data and we
don't want to continuously retrain on
all of those previous tasks and data we
want to be able to just quickly
um both computationally and and data
efficiently solve a new task
um and in all of these settings we want
the task to be able to share some
structure
Okay so we've talked about the problem
um what is the approach for actually
going about solving this problem
so
one way to view this problem is
um is kind of in contrast to supervised
learning so in supervised learning we
have inputs X and outputs why we learn a
mapping from X to Y using a data set of
input output pairs
and
in meta learning or kind of the
supervised learning variant of metal
learning
now instead of having a kind of input X
output why it's a little bit more
complicated so we have a training data
set
this trained data set has K examples
and we want to be able to learn from
this training data set in a way that
allows us to classify new examples
x-test
and so if we want to classify a new
example X test then the output will be y
test
and so in some ways you can view the
meta learning process is trying to learn
a mapping from a data set and a test
example to the corresponding label for
that test example
and the way that we can go about
learning this mapping is with a data set
of data sets
where each of these data sets is going
to have more than K examples so you can
sample k for the training data set and
at least one to be used as the test
example
and the zoo is pretty uh pretty nice
because it means that
if we view the process of learning from
small amounts of data in this way then
we simply just need to design this
function f that can take as input a data
set and generalize from that data set
um so and once we design this then we
just need to optimize it using a set of
data sets
so f is essentially representing some
form of learning procedure
and we're going to be optimizing this
learning procedure in order to learn
from data learn from small amounts of
data
and so from this standpoint we can
when designing a meta learning algorithm
we can essentially choose a form of this
learning procedure
parameterize that learning procedure in
some way
and then choose how to optimize the
parameters of that learning procedure
using some form of Maximum likelihood
objective on The Meta training data set
and I'll refer to Theta as The Meta
parameters these are the parameters that
kind of parameterizes learning
procedures so that you can learn from
data
okay so this is the general recipe
um now let's actually talk about one way
to instantiate this recipe uh and in
particular we're going to cover three
different possible instantiations one
will be referred to as Black Box
approaches another will be referred to
as optimization based approaches which
we'll cover on Wednesday and the last
will be metric learning approaches or
these more non-parametric learning
methods
Okay so
the key idea behind these black box
approaches is to essentially
parametrize the learning procedure as a
neural network
um and in particular you can just have a
neural network take his input a data set
and output parameters of a model
from that data set
and then once you output these
parameters then you can just try to
predict
the label for new data points using a
network parametrized by those parameters
Phi
um and so essentially what this might
look like is
um we have some neural network here it
might be a recurrent neural network that
takes his input the data points from
your training data set
and then uses that to Output a set of
parameters Phi
and then
you have another neural network that
uses those parameters Phi to make
predictions for new examples
and so this is essentially D train and
d-test or your support set in your query
set
and then you can train these neural
networks a um with standard supervised
learning across all of the tasks in your
meta training set
so
um essentially some over all of your
possible tasks
and uh measure how well the model with
parameters Phi is able to classify new
examples
okay and then if we refer to this as
kind of the loss function of the
parameters Phi on your held out data
points d-test
then we can also write this loss
function like this so essentially we're
using F to predict the parameters Phi
and then measuring how will the
parameters Phi generalized to test
examples
yeah it makes sense to condition like by
eye on x t s I actually have like the
test input like the parameters depend on
the test to put yeah so essentially does
it make sense to have the learning
procedure take as input the test input
and use that in the learning process in
some way
um I haven't seen that done before but I
could imagine some applications were
maybe knowing what you're going to be
asked to do at test time is informative
for the learning process
away
yeah that's a great question so
um I here is indexing the different
tasks and fire I you could actually
think of more as an activation
of this network rather than actually as
a parameter or as weights it's
essentially something that this network
is producing
the neural networks outputting weights
of another neural network and then
um those
um the output of that is using is being
used as weights of this network G here
and so it's not something Phi isn't
something that you actually represent
separately it's something that this
neural network is producing
yeah exactly so this um as you can see
in the optimization this is optimizing
the weights of this network here and
you're not actually optimizing Phi
yeah
yeah
so this is showing uh maximizing the log
likelihood um I guess I should also have
a negative sign there um this could
correspond to the negative loss function
um
um where you're minimizing the negative
log likelihood
um
and yeah
I should essentially put a I don't think
I have a way to like edit this but I
should put a negative sign
um
in the second two rows on the bottom
right
requirements
so
you can think of Phi again as a bit of
an activation and so you're not actually
training Phi in any way you're only
training the parameters of this neural
network and you're training it to Output
parameters I'll put output weights for
another neural network so that that
other neural network works well and so
Phi isn't actually being optimized here
per se it's only Theta that's being
optimized
foreign
let's look at the example of how we
could actually go about training
something like this
um
so
what we'll do is we can first sample a
task from our set of training tasks
then we or a mini batch of tasks
then we'll sample a support set in a
query set or a train set in a test set
from the data set for that task
so say for example our task is to
classify this kind of dog Landscapes
pianos and barrels
then what we'll do is we'll sample a set
of images for
um for that particular task that that NY
classification task
then we will randomly partition that
into a training set and a test set so
we'll randomly choose some images to be
used as the support set and some images
to be used as the query set
then once we have a support set in a
query set we'll compute we'll run F
forward to get a set of weights for this
particular task
and then we will evaluate how well the
network G5 does on held out examples
and back propagate our loss to update
Theta so that it effectively learned
training it to effectively learn from
this training data set in order to
classify new examples
and then we can repeat this process
again sampling a new set of tasks and
updating the learner so that it
generalizes to New examples yeah
because
the classes that correspondences
so you're asking how do you um how do
you parametrize Phi I or
yeah that's a good question so I'm in
this particular case of image
classification where your sampling
essentially a set of tasks you also need
a sample you also need to choose the
label for each of these image classes
and what's typically done in this sort
of image classification example is to
like when you sample in the five-way
classification problem when you sample
five images you just assign a one-hot ID
for each of those five classes
um at random and so you'll assign the
label of zero for Barrel a label of one
for this kind of dog label of two for
landscape and so forth
um and this does mean that across
different tasks the label of zero will
mean different things and a barrel might
be assigned to label zero and one task
and assigned to a different label and
another task
um and that sort of approach is actually
somewhat beneficial in that it prevents
the network from essentially memorizing
um memorizing the classes of the labels
of certain classes and allows it to
generalize to New Image classes which
might have different labels assigned
um
yeah so the question is um is this kind
of fully differentiable and can we take
the gradient of theta directly with
respect to the performance on the test
data points uh the answer here is is yes
um if you well in general it should be
yes there are scenarios where maybe the
parameterized G in a way that isn't
differentiable but in that case uh
you wouldn't be able to optimize it as a
normal neural network in general neural
networks uh are fully differentiable and
so you can essentially just
differentiate directly through Phi into
Theta so that you don't actually have to
optimize Phi
so that's a great question
um and we'll talk about the on the next
slide so one thing that you might notice
is that uh if if G5 is a huge neural
network then outputting all of the
parameters for a huge neural network
seems a bit impractical it doesn't seem
very scalable
and so you don't actually need to Output
all the parameters of a neural network
what you can do is essentially just um
just output something like just the
sufficient statistics or just output the
parameters of the last layer of the
network and use other parameters in G
that are kind of fixed across all of the
tasks
and so one way that you could look at
this is we can take the diagram that we
had before and replace Phi with
essentially just the kind of as some
sort of hidden Vector of like a neural
network
um and so we'll have this low
dimensional Vector h i
and this can represent essentially
contextual task information and you
could have other parts of G that have
um instead of uh you can essentially
share some parameters between Theta and
other parts of G so it's using both
Theta and h i in order to solve the task
um and so in this case Phi I will be
will correspond to the hidden param the
hidden representation H as well as some
other parameters of of theta which I'll
refer to as data sub G
which will be which could be some
separate parameters that are specific to
G in the case of an RNN it could also be
things that are shared with f as well
um now one thing that you uh one thing
that could be useful in terms of
thinking about this sort of approach is
um if we recall the multitask learning
approach where you have a network that
takes his input a description of the
task
um you could essentially
think of the description of the task as
this hi
or in some more general form you could
essentially view the description of the
task zi as it's corresponding to a data
set for that task
um and so essentially instead of
conditioning on a task description
you're conditioning the network on a
data set
cool any questions on on how this works
before we move on
so the question is is this excluding
like does this means that you have to
have the same loss function for all of
the tasks
foreign
yeah so this is a good question so
actually I mean this the way that I
presented this actually means like in
general I think that people typically
assume that you have the same loss
function across all of the tasks
um in principle instead of only costly
in the data set you could also pass some
information about the loss function
and if the loss function is training
across tasks
foreign
yeah so the
there's a few different ways that you
can think of this
um Theta G might be something that's
completely separate that's optimized
alongside the parameters of f it could
also be things that are something that's
shared with f so if you essentially just
kind of collapse these two things
together then you can view it as just a
single over current neural network
that has
um that kind of shares all of its
parameters and H I just corresponds to
the uh the recurrent state of that RNN
right
now uh I think you've earnings uh one
natural question is like this is a kind
of one way to represent it we have a
black box neural network that takes them
for the data set and a new Test example
and outputs predictions
now what architecture should we actually
use for f Theta
um there are a variety of choices here
uh one example or one of the kind of
initial examples that that looked at
this kind of problem used either lstms
or what's referred to as a neural turing
machine which has this kind of form of
external memory that it's using to kind
of in the learning process
um now a more recent architecture that I
think is quite nice uh is something that
instead of uses some sort of kind of
recurrent neural network or an external
membrane mechanism is what it does it
just takes all the inputs from your
training examples and uh
run the feed forward neural network on
each of those training examples and then
averages the predictions averages the
embeddings of that feed forward Network
into a single context
um and then that single context is used
by the network G in order to make
predictions
um so does anyone have any thoughts on
why something like a feed forward and
then averaging architecture for
competing the context might be better
than something like a recurrent neural
network
yeah
[Music]
yeah exactly so a recurrent architecture
is going to assume that there's a
particular ordering to each of the data
sets but in reality a data set is
usually a set not a sequence and a feed
forward and averaging architecture will
essentially encode the fact that data
points are permutation invariant and it
doesn't matter uh the order of the
particular data points and so this is
kind of the main advantage of an
architecture like this what additional
architecture one additional Advantage is
that it is often computationally cheaper
to to run feed forward and averaging
because you can completely paralyze
things whereas in recurrent neural
networks you can't parallelize each step
as easily
um but the uh the permutation and
variance is really the main benefit
yeah
[Music]
definitely so if you have a really large
support set
um an RNN can can certainly forget
things over time whereas this sort of
feed forward an average
um it can sort of also forget things in
some way but it's not going to be
forgetting in like a sequence dependent
way
okay I'm in there's also some other
architectures that people have used as
well other kinds of external memory
mechanisms people have also used things
like attention as well uh
um and temporal convolutions
things like attention are also nice in
the sense that they are also permutation
invariant depending on how some of the
implementation details
okay
um and then if you actually run uh the
architecture on the far right on a few
shot image classification problem
um like the Omni glut data set which is
a character recognition data set
you can see that the
um you can perform one shot five-way
image classification with around 99
accuracy for new characters that it's
never seen before so consistently learn
to recognize uh yeah new characters with
just a single example per character
which is pretty cool
um and then beyond kind of the character
recognition task we can actually also
look at them in the imagenet task this
is actually the exact example that I was
showing on the previous slides and
architecture like the one on the far
right gets around a 55 or 68 accuracy on
a five-way classification problem when
you're either given one example per
class or five examples per class
cool um and so in homework one uh you're
going to be implementing uh kind of the
data processing
training setup essentially for these
kinds of future image classification
problems you'll Implement a very simple
Black Box metal learner and then also
just train a few shot Omni Glock
classifier and hopefully get numbers
that aren't too far off from the numbers
that we thought of
great okay
um any more questions or I'm gonna I'm
thinking about running through an
example
okay so
um already an example and in particular
the in your homework you're going to be
using the Omni lot data set
this is a data set that has 1600 16 to
23 characters
from 50 different alphabets
and so an example of some of the
alphabets are shown here
and um each character has 20 different
instances so essentially they had 20
different people write that character
and um
for for all the characters in the data
set
and one of the things that's kind of
cool about this data set is it has
many different character classes and
only a few examples per character class
and in some ways this is kind of like
the transpose of a lot of common data
sets first it's kind of like the
transpose of mnus because in mnist you
have 10 classes and you have thousands
of examples per class
and I also think that
the statistics of a data set like this
are actually much more reflective of the
real world where you have kind of very
broad data and a very small amount of
examples per class
um for example
um kind of probably over your lifetime
you for many objects you probably
haven't seen like thousands of different
instances of that object before you've
probably only seen
um well depending on how old you are
maybe you've seen only a few instances
maybe you've seen maybe 100 instances
but probably not
a
ton
okay so I want to run through an example
um from this problem and this will I
think will be should be quite helpful
for your homework
so we'll see that we're doing uh let's
say that we're doing kind of
three-way
One-Shot classification
and we want to be able to do this on
Omni glut
and so
at test time or
at meta test time we're given a new task
and we have
a training data set for that task
which will be
three different images
maybe a b and Z from the English
alphabet and we'll assign a label for
each of these images maybe y equals zero
y equals one and Y equals two
and then we also have
a test example which will be an image
for uh maybe a written in a slightly
different way and you want your goal is
to be able to predict kind of the
correct label for this which is y equals
zero
this is what we have admitted test time
and then I'll do all of
meditating on this whiteboard so
kind of during meta training what should
happen
so maybe the English alphabet is held
out or character or at least these
characters from the English alphabet are
completely held out
and so
uh what is maybe kind of the first thing
that we should do during metatrading
if we're uh or if we kind of want to
compute the gradient step on our Network
what's the the first thing that we
should do
um
I'm going to going to do something a
little bit more crude and simply we're
going to kind of put all the alphabets
together we're going to sample three
different characters they could be from
the same alphabet they could be from
different alphabets
um and we're going to be in the setting
where we're just going to kind of train
for the three-way one classification
problem so we're that's why we're going
to be sampling three characters
um and then we're going to be
sampling
multiple instances per character
and because we're in the one shot
setting we want to sample at least one
instance for the support set
and we also need to be able to sample
some instances for the query set
and so
we're going to sample
kind of two
I guess
two images
kind of per character
is this can everyone see this by the way
is this big enough
cool
okay
and then uh we could just sample these
at random and then we need to
um maybe I can draw this out maybe we
have like
uh Alpha
I guess these are actually are from the
same alphabet alphabetic gamma um and
then we'll also have
um we'll sample
other instances that are Maybe
drawn slightly differently
then once you have these samples we need
to use some for the support set and some
for the query set so we will
kind of assign these to be all from for
the support set and all these for the
query set and then we'll also need to
assign labels for each of these so uh
maybe we'll give this a label of two a
label of one and a label of zero and
likewise this will have a label of two a
label of one and a label of zero
okay and then from here we're
essentially ready to actually pass this
data into the network so this is the
kind of the data processing step
and then once we have this we'll
essentially
kind of pass D train
into our neural network
we'll also sample one of the examples
from d-test
so maybe it's uh
this will be
this image right here
and note that when we pass in D train
we're going to be passing in both the
images and the labels
whereas here we don't want to pass in
the label because we don't want to give
it the answer right
um so we'll pass this into the network
as well
and then
it's going to predict y hat
and then we're going to compute how good
y hat is so we'll have some loss
function that compares y hat to the true
label which is two
and then we can take the gradient of
this with respect to Theta so maybe
there are weights Theta here and we'll
use this to update the network
does that example make sense do people
have any questions
from
different
yeah so the question is why are we
allowing it to potentially sample
classes across alphabets and each and
each task be a different alphabet
um there are different ways to design
the problem and what it is very valid to
essentially kind of keep past
constrained to individual alphabets and
when I wrote These it was actually
constrained to the alphabets but
um
one thing that can be helpful is if you
don't concern it to an alphabet then you
can essentially get more
data more tasks and so it's essentially
kind of a form of task augmentation in
the sense which is that instead of only
considering tasks within an alphabet you
could also consider tasks that are
classifying examples
um
kind of across different alphabets as
well
um and this will essentially generate
more tasks for meta training
um and then in the homework we will also
be uh we won't actually be holding out
an entire alphabet we'll just be holding
out characters from across different
alphabets in a very realistic scenario
maybe it is actually an entirely new
alphabet that you want to be able to
test on and in that case you would
actually if you want to prepare for that
scenario you do actually want to held
out hold out an entirely uh entirely
distinct alphabet during the metatrading
process to test whether the method is
actually good at that
leadership
yeah so um with the form of task
augmentation you're still essentially
like preparing the method to be able to
quickly classify examples for a new
alphabet and so maybe during this meta
training process you don't actually have
data for the test alphabet available and
you want it to be able to to make
predictions for for a new alphabet kind
of on the Fly
um if you do have all of the all of the
alphabets available ahead of time then
you can also use a multitask learning
approach rather than a meta learning
approach
is it
like
um
yeah so typically the um if you want to
prepare it for one shot learning it's
good to give it One-Shot learning tasks
at meta training time because that will
kind of prepare it for exactly what it
will see at meta test time you can also
train it on variable shots like some
some tasks that are one taught some
tasks that are five shots some tests
that are three top three shot
um and that should in principle also
prepare it for different kinds of tasks
including One-Shot tasks one thing that
you want to avoid is if you train it for
five shot tasks and then test it on a
One-Shot task it probably won't do well
in that case because you're training it
to be able to learn from large data sets
and then asking it to be able to perform
a task where you only have a small
amount of data and so you're not
preparing it for what it will see at
test time
that's a great question so actually
people often do exactly that which is
that you train it for one shot and then
you test it for maybe one shot or more
than one shot and one shot is the
hardest setting it often actually
prepares it for the one shot setting and
also for settings that are a bit easier
than that
enabled
based on hierarchies
yeah so if you if you trade it on like
five shot and then test it on one shot
you're breaking the ID assumption and
that's exactly why it performs poorly
um it is valid to still train it on
variable shot as long as the thing that
you're gonna be testing it on is uh is a
part of that and is sufficiently
represented in the the kinds of tasks
you're training on
yeah so the question is um how is what I
said before breaking the IID assumption
so if all of your tasks are our
five-shot learning tasks and a test time
you're given a One-Shot learning task
then um The one-spot Learning task or
problem isn't actually
um
isn't represented in the distribution of
tasks that you see during training
um in that sense one of the things
that's kind of interesting about task
distributions is it's not just like
what's in the data and the loss function
it's also the size of the data set as
well
[Music]
yeah so in practice um training on one
shot and testing on five shot actually
still works pretty well
um in like completely like in theory it
shouldn't work well in some sense
because you're training it for something
that you're not testing it on something
um the reason why in practice it works
well is you're kind of testing it on a
setting this easier than the training
setting
um
I guess that one thing that I should
also mention is if you're literally if
you're
if you're using an RNN uh like using an
RNN and you train it for one shot and
then you test it on five shot
um if you're rolling out the RNN for
longer than you trained it for it will
actually perform very poorly and so for
RNN type methods you don't want to go
from one shot to five shot but for a lot
of other metal learning methods they
usually work well when you train on one
shot and test on five shot because of
some of because of how they add
structure into the algorithm
yeah foreign
is
um
so the question is kind of
um talking a little bit more about kind
of a real world use case of this and so
forth um the I guess the the typical the
use case of this is what one where maybe
you have like you take a picture of
images it is a kind of it's not a zero
shot setting like if you see a character
that wasn't seen in the trained is that
you take a picture of it it's not going
to be able to classify it because it's
just simply not enough information
um and so the application is something
where
um maybe you have
um maybe you want to deploy something in
a new country and you collect a small
amount of data for characters from that
country maybe to help with like the
postal service or something like that
and um
and you don't want to collect the
massive data set for that you want to
just collect a very small data set
because that will be very cheap and so
you take images of of characters from
that new alphabet and um and then use
that to train a classifier so that you
can deploy that classifier on like all
of the mail from that country or
something does that make sense
great yeah
um
pretty welcome files yeah so the
question is
um what are the implications of using a
neural network to Output the weights of
another neural network are we kind of
contradicting the inductive bias of
neural networks
um I think that the it's possible
um I guess
in general this sort of idea of
outputting Weights of another neural
network is referred to as hyper networks
uh sometimes and it's possible that this
will not retain some of the induct nice
inductive biases of neural networks when
the weights come from another neural
network
um
and we will actually see in the kind of
coming lectures approaches that have
better inductive biases including metric
learning approaches uh and a more
optimization-based approaches
um where the weights aren't coming from
another Network
yeah so what is how many tasks do we
need in general like I said before the
more the better
um and it really it ends up being
somewhat problem specific and domain
specific if the tasks are relatively
simple you might not need that many
um if you have a very broad distribution
of tasks and you're going to need more
tasks to cover that broad distribution
there is some work that tries to
theoretically characterize how the
number of tasks impacts performance I
think that there's some work by Richard
zimmel for example at Toronto that
studies that and they do look at some
bounds but that's uh kind of beyond what
we'll look at in this course
okay um and then a couple more things
worth mentioning here um this was an
example in Omniglot there are also a
number of other image recognition data
sets like cfar Cubs celebrate and orbit
Orbit's actually a pretty nice example
it's it's coming from the standpoint of
trying to build classifiers for blind or
visually impaired users where the user
will like take pictures of their items
I'll take only a few pictures naturally
and then you want to be able to allow
them to build a classifier for their
items using those pictures
um there's also benchmarks that are
outside of the image recognition domain
here are a few examples and if you're
interested in looking at data sets for
your projects these benchmarks could be
interesting
okay
um and then to summarize uh kind of the
Black Box approach and this pros and
cons
um these sorts of networks are very
expressive because they're essentially
parameterizing a learning procedure
through using a potentially very large
neural network
um it's also very easy to combine this
kind of approach with a variety of
different problems including supervised
learning and reinforcement learning
um there are some downsides so in
general you're trying to learn how to
learn from scratch essentially you're
trying to learn this learning procedure
from completely randomly initialize the
weights of a neural network and this
leads to a fairly challenging
optimization procedure
and as a result it can sometimes be data
inefficient in terms of the tasks that
you need for meta training
and so there are other ways that we can
essentially represent these learning
procedures and next time on Wednesday
we're going to be looking at how we can
essentially treat it as an optimization
procedure and parametrize an
optimization procedure
um
as part of the learning process rather
than using a neural network to represent
the entire learning procedure